[Musik]
so hat das ist unser jahresrückblick was
war dein highlight 2018
außer dass du dein leben mit mir
verbringen
ja bei uns herbstmeister geworden
er sagt ja das gab es mal eine chance
gehörte aber ganz unten
was war dein highlight in bezug auf
unserem kanal
dieses jahr haben wir monats fünf
minuten eingeführt school wasser
hier gab es fünf minuten
murat ernsthaft diesmal diesmal schaffen
muss auf jeden fall berühmt-berüchtigt
ja auch geschafft
ich lehne ich das auch geschafft helene
wenig doch herkömmlich also dann scheint
es auch los fünf minuten jetzt das ist
ein freund von mir
der grüne ist hesse und zwar er kann
auch er kann weder kochen noch backen
aber er ist hesse und ihr kind auf den
spruch was die schwaben nicht fressen
fressen die hessen und afrika helfen
soll
die champignons angreifen soll ja auf
jeden fall werden wir das machen rezepte
ändern zwei esslöffel öl und ich finde
es auch die letzten jahre zwei echten
verlust wenn man es so sieht gering und
vor allem im juni ja und jetzt die
nächste rein
[Musik]
und jetzt muss ich nur drehen
das kriegst auch noch hinter das ist gar
nichts wie blöd kann man eigentlich
sagen
[Gelächter]
die stubengasse gemacht hat
ok genau jetzt dreht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja egal mir persönlich das beste
rauszuholen aus dem rezept kannst du
eigentlich so die fahne zu schwenken so
cool ja klar natürlich fast aufkommen
[Musik]
das war zunächst ein eigenes tage wenn
er es denn gerne globus einkaufen geht
man sagen die leute kommen da kommt der
fernseher ist da jetzt und so und seine
ehemaligen arbeitskollegen die haben den
whatsapp gruppe gegründet und fallen im
juni tot war
da kann er ja auch klar danny wilde hat
aber gesagt er will jetzt geld haben ja
echt ja und sein eigenes management
jetzt und möchte uns völlig war ja also
ich find s 5 genial weil der
ursprungsgedanke war ja dass ich so ein
bisschen mehr zeit für mich habe und für
andere dinge und murat minuten zeit
abnimmt ein bisschen arbeit abnimmt und
ich glaube das ist uns ganz gut gelungen
zwischendurch nicht so ganz es macht
auch spaß kochen auf geringes
bildungsniveau ist macht es da ja kochen
auf geringen belastung ist doch ein
wahnsinn verwandeln jetzt machte mario
eska papa mario sich erste ernsthafte
jetzt mal hieß die panne ist ja es ist
so ein blödmann soll die pfanne da
stehen bleiben
die stimmung bleibt stehen
jetzt habe ich das mal frei gemacht aber
ich lasse kuchen erstmal kurz abkühlen
und zwar abkühlen heiße sich die jetzt
im kühlschrank einstellen das wäre
falsch warum das passiert sonst bin ich
arm ist im kühlschrank gestellt
südwasser wasser hat auch schon wasser
gezogen
so wie man das blech es heißt nicht
anpassen einfach nur abkühlen lassen
ich meine er wollte mir arbeit abnehmen
aber er hat halt ein huhn dass mubarak
in ihrer allerletzten dabei war es war
so lustig wohl ein lehrvideo machen
ein lehrvideo mit doppel
bildungsfernsehen wollte ich machen
genau geht voll in die hose weil es wohl
nicht so wie wir wollten ich kann nicht
trainer reja war genial
ich wollte die jungs normalen lebens und
zeigen um die wundervoll dieses jahr
nicht ist und ich habe den ball
beauftragt bitte doch einen hut zu
bringen vom biohof der hat auch gemacht
und was dann passiert ist das sicherlich
mal jetzt
also wenn ich das was heute hier
passiert ist jemandem erzähle es glaubt
kein mensch glaubt kein mensch
ich habe doch nur gesagt roten hohen ich
hab' ich hab ich wohl nur unruhen haben
ich bin nun haben mehr wollte ich nichts
der karton hierauf gerade hier vorne und
dann habe ich einfach nur noch mit der
kamera draufgehalten
er habe den koffer aufgemacht und dann
ist ja alles eskaliert und ich kein geld
zu versprechen
ich weiß nicht aber es war grausam also
ich komme hierher um bei der fälle im
kaffee zu trinken
dann steht der kleine dicke in der küche
mit einem huhn
ich habe damit nichts zu tun
ich wollte ihm rooney etwas tun möglich
ist ich wollte ihn ruiniert was tun
ich habe wirklich gedacht die leute oder
alle kennen sie im raum mit tieren aus
aber musste ich das noch niemandem
kontakt im tier hatte
[Musik]
diesmal holt nico fange ich aber nicht
und wird achter platz ein sammelplatz
schreiber drumherum war cooles video war
auch wirklich was zu lernen denke ich
war humorvoll etwas beigebracht
jetzt wissen wir alle warum wir kein
hohen in der küche haben möchten genau
und vorsatz vorliegt es ja weniger
fleisch kriege ich das gerät das
schriftlich von den weniger gefragt ja
ihr habt gepackt weil ich jetzt muss ich
noch mal reden nein ich rede nur gegen
raumfahrer ist normal sonst machte aber
von ella immer noch schwärmt ist
lektorin es war der familienurlaub
schlechthin
das war auch einer der coolsten videos
das war das war einfach der hammer
also die ella immer wenn sie irgendwie
erzählt wenn ich sage was sollten wir
machen sagt ihr mann war nach efteling
fahren nach öfter legen und jetzt immer
noch gehört immer noch
[Musik]
ein forum für harburg hat beim
sprechenden märchen wahr und der ist so
wunderschön gemacht also wie aus dem
märchen von wahnsinn und die
erleichterte weiß kann man so sagen soll
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und alles muss es sagen wir nehmen den
kindern weg geht ist mein mann gavin
bauhof das ist richtig genial auf dem
bauernhof urlaub zu machen mit den
kindern in die natur zu gehen und ich
finde so ein urlaub in einem
freizeitpark wird völlig unter börse ja
vor allen dingen wenn du in einen
richtigen freizeitpark geht ist ein echt
zum park wo du einfach mit kleinen
kindern hin karriere hat was da von mir
hat es spaß gemacht ich glaube ich hatte
den meisten spaß stören
es existiere europapark ja ja ja mal
europa park gibt es wieder tolle
freizeitparks genau
und dann kam auf einmal in den signal
iduna park gehen weiß oder ist weil es
nicht mehr sagt er nicht beginnen weil
das ist ein stadion genau gewusst was
auch richtig toll war dieses jahr über
österreich österreich
[Musik]
dublin
denn es gibt
[Musik]
ja früher war das immer so meine freunde
in der schulzeit war immer so wo geht er
hin ferien
wir sind dann mit meinen eltern in die
türkei nicht oft aber wir waren und
meine freunde sind immer noch reich und
ich dachte mir was wollen die da
österreich ist genauso wie deutschland
aber nein ist das gar nicht irgendwie
ist es fast komplett eigenes österreich
habe mich wirklich überrascht positiv
hole coole landschaft das essen cooles
volk muss man ganz ganz ehrlich sagen
und nicht umsonst das hauptreiseziel der
deutsch-österreicher was er sagt und
wenn es euch mal aufgefallen ist leute
also die die kinder wo ich damals noch
schilling hast du gar nicht reden
das gelang mir hat mir das weißt du als
kind wo wenn ihr uns eltern waren die
gebildet waren eltern eltern
[Musik]
die hellen gern nicht die dunkle nicht
die schwarzen was ist das schwarze l
hier gegen kaká ich habe gefahren zu
sein
das nächste thema waren schöne
österreich willkommen niederoesterreich
schule ist als nächstes jahr wieder in
österreich
nach kaffee tourette ist ja ich habe
verantwortung gegeben hast du schon
verloren was ich nächstes jahr hat das
war's kinder wohnen auch die
wissenschaft ein kinderwunsch maschine
auf dem zettel darauf kinderwunsch nein
kinderküche was ich weiß nichts vom
kinder- und hat auf mich ständig zu
fragen ob ich schwanger werden hier über
das kränkt den monat genau will ich
schwanger bin
nein und zwar kind ja wohl noch mal ein
kind und das thema ist kinderkirche
versorgt
ja natürlich haben die kinder küche
gepaart mit sanierer
wir versuchen jetzt eine kinderküche für
unter 25 eur zu bauen
[Musik]
wir haben es geschafft eine kinderkirche
für unter 25 eur zu bauen
wichtiger als der preis ist aber das
selbermachen und das gemeinsame werkeln
mit dem kind das selbe bauen steigt das
selbstbewusstsein des kindes
kinder können oft viel mehr als die
erwachsenen ihnen zutrauen kinder
brauchen selbstbewusstsein damit sie
stark sind und an sich glauben die
eltern schenken ihnen aufmerksamkeit und
anerkennung ermuntern die kinder so dass
die eigenen fähigkeiten gestärkt und
gefördert werden
und das beginnt schon beim bau in einer
kinderküche das kind merkt dann hab ich
habe die fähigkeit ziele zu erreichen
häufig konzentrieren sich eltern im
alltagsstress auf das was kinder nicht
so gut können oder nicht schaffen
dabei ist es viel wichtiger den
blickwinkel zu ändern und zu schauen was
das kind eben schon gut kann lobt eure
kinder nicht nur mit worten sondern auch
mit gesten und blicken die einzelnen
fähigkeiten der kinder sollten gezielt
gefördert werden damit aus ihnen
selbstbewusster und glückliche menschen
werden
richtig cool und er liebt diese küche
kocht und backt jeden tag in ihrer
kinder richtig cooles video auch mit
mamas kinderkirche bauen unter 25 eur
und es ist uns gelungen
wenn ihr mehr sowie videos sehen möchte
dann schreibt gern in der kolpin ich
will es sinnvolle videos sind also ich
bin einfach videos zu machen wo wirklich
ein gewisses bildungsniveau haben meine
videos dann raus guck mal die
videospiele an den geringes
bildungsniveau habt und um nochmal auf
den kinderwunsch zu von zwei wundervolle
töchter und dann noch dich noch manchen
wurde und wohl auch gut und wenn ich mal
ein bisschen dickeren bauch ab und
stürzte dann nicht nur daran dass ich
gerade gegessen haben ja hier ist immer
wisst ihr ich finde es auch nicht okay
ich mein es ist schon so in der
gesellschaft dass frauen immer perfekt
sein müssen und mamas immer perfekt und
dann muss man die perfekte mama sein die
perfekte ehefrau sein
lasst mich doch ein bart bebauung dem
durch noch nicht zum beispiel wisst ihr
das kränkt mich auch nächstes und
außerdem musik auf der schürze das thema
für den halt direkt auf meine bau wohnen
sie zahlt manchmal aus als erwartet
dann haben wir sechs unternehmer machen
john deere traktor hat mir kool savas
den ablauf des videos kaputt egal wir
arbeiten ähnlich einfach die liste ab
okay wir unsere highlight aber da steht
es doch drauf ich lese ist doch dass ich
meinen schmerz vergessen
john deere traktor war ein cooles video
das man richtig cooles video
[Musik]
der traktor wird nämlich 100 jahre alt
und zu diesem anlass habe ich mir
gedacht kommt erlebbar keine 3d torte
viele von euch haben sich ja bereits
einen traktor gewünscht ich backe
arbeitet orten nicht alleine zu hause
ich habe unterstützung nicht von john d
aber mindestens genauso wichtig kommt
mit in die küche zu gast habe ich bei
mir im markt von penns vorstand bei john
deere die ganz genau dass ich ein
bisschen kalorienreicher kuchen verteilt
kein weight watchers rezept der john
deere traktor wurde nämlich 100 jahre
alt und ich habe einen traktor gebaut
aus kuchen genau und der wird übrigens
in deutschland hergestellt er wird schon
die traktor coole geschichte
amerikanische unternehmen wurden
traktoren welt bei in deutschland
hergestellt werden und zwar in mannheim
richtig cool und in bruchsal machen sei
die kabinen
genau da arbeitet nämlich der papa von
also der arbeit und unser freund genau
heißt drucker tolle arbeit wird und wem
er von john deere etwas geschaut oder
möchte gehaltserhöhung
aber ihr seid ehrlich gesagt lieber
markt von pence der ist das c o pop mit
emotionen die richtige haltung ja im
september sind wir immer traditionell
auf der ifa und seit etwa drei jahren
das seit zwei jahren bei bosch und es
ist echt immer richtig cool also wir
treffen manchmal bekannte gesichter aber
ganz ganz viele neue gesichter und ich
freue mich schon auf die nächste ifa
da wird wieder richtig lecker mein herz
hast du was nicht
diese frau ist
ich weiß schon dass ich echt ganz
sensibel bündnisse in trampe bin nicht
man kann nicht mehr auf sein wartezimmer
warten
[Musik]
ja auch mal leute wo wir nicht gern
sehen würden wenn deine familie kommt
jetzt konnten zwar nicht so gemeint von
mir ja die wahl war ganz cool nicht so
wie man es ganz cool und die ifa messe
in berlin empfiehlt jedem fall euch der
ganz große geschichte er wenn man sich
neu einrichten sondern nach ideen die
hamas ist ganz cool
[Musik]
dieses jahr das highlight bei uns war
eigentlich die neue küche und ich habe
mir das so ich habe mir ist wie in so
einem märchen vorgestellt wir schließen
den der alten küche ab und dann machen
wir sommerpause und dann wollen wir die
neue küche hier ein weißt doch mit einem
roten band zu durchschneiden und dann
feiern alle wir machen einen live stream
das problem war nur wir konnten es nicht
so machen weil parallel die vox sendung
schon angefangen hat und wir haben schon
angefangen für vox zu drehen
und irgendwann so misch masch schon
irgendwie war das so ein schleichender
prozess von der alten zur neuen küche
was ich ziemlich schade fand denn die
alte küche wir waren da seid 2013 oder
und ich meine ich habe da vier jahre
lang videos gedreht und in decke hier
ist alles so nicht entstanden aber in
der küche haben wir alles so weit so
optimiert dass alles entstanden kinder
kuchen alles war nicola küche ich würde
sie müssen ja ich hatte am anfang fiel
es mir auch schwer ich habe mich hier
noch nicht so ganz wohl gefühlt war so
heißt auch nicht aber die alte kirche
war einfach irgendwann zu klein
ihr müsst euch vorstellen die ganzen
mitarbeiter bei uns und dann immer
geklingelt und es war einfach ich konnte
nicht mal mehr einen kuchen tablett
abstellen weil alles voller kameras und
stativ wir haben fünf jahre gebraucht
bis ich weiß wohl alles war und er sie
ins im roggen oder 20 gar nichts mehr
die eigenen füße nicht mehr wohl ganz
schlimm ja dann die männer leiden mit
dir die wissen alle nicht wo die das
geschehen ist genau und ja aber jetzt
muss ich sagen fühle ich mich richtig
wohl
wir hatten ja auch die küche erst grün
jetzt haben wir in beton optik und ich
fühle mich jetzt echt wohl und ich
glaube das merkt man jetzt mal wieder
locker in der küche und ich weiß
zumindest wo alles steht eigentlich
alles wie früher weil du fragst mich
immer wo alles steht genau und du hast
sogar angesprochen box einfach berlin
fahren sicher highlight war und richtig
coole sind
[Musik]
ich freue mich auf meine neue sendung
und ab
[Musik]
bei der sendung muss ich echt sagen
haben oftmals gefragt auch bei facebook
was gefällt euch was gefällt euch nicht
oder gab es wirklich so dass 99 prozent
der der zuschauer diese dass die sendung
gefallen haben die 1 prozent haben sich
für folgende sachen beschwert wo ich
recht gebe oder wir haben uns jetzt
bleibt ist normal zu kurz viel zu kurz
für 25 minuten und in der zeit um
dieselbe zeit da war nicht nur günstig
ungünstig sind katastrophal
ganz einfach weil es wirklich auch so
muss man ehrlich sagen sonntag sind mir
selber mit der familie unterwegs und
schaute noch nie zu hause haben 60
familien zu hause entfernt nach draußen
bei gutem wetter oder wissen ob daraus
eine schlechte oder bei freunden bei
freunden daheim 82
unsere zuschauer sind familien familien
die zwischen 18 und 54 sind und die
meisten leute war ich zu hause als
lernen
das war richtig blöd also eine uhrzeit
geht eigentlich kaum noch oder außer
fünf uhr morgens sonntag
ja weil doch bilde gewesen die sendung
an sich also haben wir echt nur
positives feedback gekriegt und somit im
team hat es mir super viel spaß gemacht
und vor allem konnten wir halt auch viel
neues ausprobieren also klar mein
youtube videos immer völlig frei in
allem wir können machen was wir wollen
weil wir halt alles selber machen und
alles auf einem kanal hoch warten
aber wir haben einfach nicht die zeit
und oft die möglichkeiten mal
rauszugehen und weißt du es doch so viel
auch zumal viele sachen auch die
erfahrung gar nicht muss man auch sagen
und das war echt richtig toll auch
richtig komik box muss man sagen ja es
hat mich unterstützt
nur wie gesagt die sendezeit und da
kunden wieder anderes machen ja und ja
und falls ihr euch die sendung noch
anschauen wollt de gibt es immer noch
auf tv könnt ihr euch gerne alle noch
mal anschauen und am pc ist übrigens
kostenfrei genau und nächstes jahr
gucken wir mal gucken mal ist noch
nichts geplant
ja es wird sie partnern verändern aber
ich glaub ich weiß nicht ob mixa was
kommt weil wir uns auf andere sachen
kultur
man muss auch sagen der dreh war
superschön
mit dem wachstum aber es war natürlich
auch sehr zeitintensiv also ich hab da
drehtage habt ihr gegen echt von morgens
um sieben bis abends um zehn oder noch
länger teilweise weil du stand fertig
machen wenn du gerade beim apfelbauern
bis und er hat sich an dem tag die zeit
genommen
dann muss eben auch an diesem tag findet
machen und ja das war echt ein wunder
wunderschöne erfahrung was noch ja es
gab es noch für highlights dieses jahr
ich mein haus erfasst werde ich ja bauen
ja nach hause fast fertig können wir
zeigen mal unseren zuschauern den garten
denn wir bald haben werden
und da draußen da hamma bald unseren
garten das hier ist eigentlich für
unsere drohen aber vielleicht kann ich
damit den murat steuern kann mir
probiert es mal wieso renten der durch
den garten und und und
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
du musst sie nutzen sein sprung in
strengen level vorbei
[Musik]
also eins wir jetzt zu sagen ich will
nicht mehr selber bauen ich auch nicht
ich will nicht mehr machen ich würde es
kein geld um keiner zeit ja sozusagen
nur hast du nerven er und vor allem wenn
man vollzeit berufstätige dann doch zu
bauen und dann auch selber bauen das
katastrophe ich glaube kein mensch bau
zweieinhalb jahre lang kein mensch
machen ehe sie haben es gemacht wo sie
immer nicht werde ich die außenanlage
steht noch nicht die außenanlagen und
das problem ist ein buch hat mir immer
so am anfang des jahres für januar
februar hat er immer gesagt vertrau mir
dieses jahr im winter das immer schon im
neuen haus und ich alles klar das habe
ich immer im januar februar wenn es dann
wärmer wurde irgendwann meine ganzen
jacken schon in kartons gesteckt sally
winterkleidung und dann ins lager also
in die garage oder im keller
sodann war winter ich wusste nicht mehr
wo die jacken sind habe ich mir letztes
der neue jacken holen müssen eine und
dieses diesem frühjahr märz habe ich
wieder ok hat exakt dieses thema aber
fertig habe ich wieder meine jacke im
karton gepackt mit schal und mütze sally
winterkleidung wieder weg so dieser bin
ich einfach mit zwei dicken pullovern
rumgelaufen jahrgang aber jetzt jetzt
mehr fertig jetzt im rhein und im märz
zwar wieder auseinander auch weil ich
das haus
das haus ist laut handelsblatt 1
innovative häuser und europaweit ein
cooles smart home system und das ist
nachhaltig wir brauchen kein strom von
draußen brauchen kein heizöl wir
brauchen kein gas man alles selber und
wenn die photovoltaik-anlage auf dem
dach nicht ausreicht da haben wir so ein
hamsterrad von murat im keller oder
fahrrad ganz cool aber da hat zufolge
auch dem nächstes jahr ein paar coole
videos alles gemacht haben aber nochmal
da haben auch irgendwann die updates
nicht mehr so regelmäßig machen können
weil zu viel parallel passiert ist dann
nur die vox sendung dann hat er drehen
der küche dann war draußen wird gebaut
und dann wird es irgendwann ein bisschen
viel
und dann haben wir natürlich wenn ich
jetzt ein video über die küche machen
will will ich ja zeigen von der
entstehung bis zum ende aber wir sind
noch nicht am ende daher gab es also es
gibt wenn wir komplett fertig sind alle
videos so in einem
genau oder ja dann kann man sagen es war
dort geht es um alles was ich werden
wollte zeige ja videos ein paar coole
videos nächstes jahr auch ein paar coole
videos zu einrichten wird es richtig
cool geben wir halten es noch ein
highlight war doch was wenn ich gedacht
doch ich weiß sagt billig dass ali merza
mein gott bewusst was für ein zufall
ja und zwar ein highlight war dass wir
unseren ersten ad sowie ausgebildet
haben
denn es fertig das wirklich gewonnen
musste und dann haben wir unsere zweite
art sowie eingestellt weil ihn genau wir
haben zwei azubis und holte eine
zufällig ich bin zu einhundert drauf
echt ehrlich das ist für mich schon ein
riesen highlight nur zwei junge menschen
ich meine ich vermiss oft mein lehrer
beruf muss ich echt sagen das fragen
mich auch fehle
ob ich noch als lehrerin arbeitet und
ich vermisse es einfach mit kindern zu
arbeiten
aber es ist auch schön und dann finde
ich bin ich wieder so ein bisschen
zurück in meinem lehrerberuf ich bin
einfach menschen aus und ich meinen mann
falsches da draußen kindergartens
gestorben so ein bisschen kindergarten
ja und was war sonst noch was vergessen
und mich unnötigen auszeichnen wir
hatten auch richtig
[Musik]
kinder sind gewachsen sind so groß
geworden und dann das ist ein zweiter
klasse die ela ist in der grundschule
nicht so weitermacht ist murat a ist
schon ein kleiner räuber genau die guckt
sich an mit ihren großen augen sondern
kann steht nicht böse sein wenn jetzt
gratis zuschaut wir brauchen dich und
dann ja was heute noch zu sagen was man
im sommer also nächster machen morath
und grüne auf jeden fall monats fünf
minuten weiter ein eigenes logo würde
ich sagen ja wir kriegen als logo und
dann ist unfair wenn das immer noch
monats minuten heißt weil eigentlich
eure finger morath und hast du echt toll
gemacht es ist heißt es wackelig
wir wollen die sendezeit ändern
ah ja genau die sind wir zeugen weil wir
gemerkt haben die mittwoch freitag 11 wo
ich immer so naja sind die meisten in
der schule bei der arbeit im büro
vielleicht könnt ihr ja einfach mal eine
uhrzeit schreiben um welche uhrzeit
sondern wir in zukunft unsere videos
hochladen in der wand laufen weiterhin
mittwoch freitags sonntags videos 2 von
mir einst von moment genau und ihr dürft
euch jetzt die uhrzeit mal aussuchen und
die abstimmung so wie sie daneben läuft
so machen auf welche uhrzeit seine
videos anfangen 18 uhr 18 uhr vielleicht
ja genau das müssen wir einfach mal
gucken was euch gefällt ja ansonsten
glaube ich sollten wir im nächsten jahr
endlich mal unseren live stream machen
ja live stream aus der küche jetzt haben
wir auch den platz jetzt kann man das
mal machen dann können wir live zusammen
kochen und backen nach italien
genau italien wird auch so gern eine
türkei-reise machen und ich möchte
wieder nach österreich
also da hat österreich rundreise ist
wegen der woche nach österreich
wir suchen links suchen kleinere
unternehmen ja also regionale erzeuger
wir gehen nach italien werden genau das
gleiche machen wie man in deutschland
würden mit ist auch gerne machen ihr
müsst ihr uns einfach mal anschreiben
und der knoblauch bäuerin sagt genau wie
club haben wir hier in der ecke und dich
besuchen auf jeden fall genau und
ansonsten falls ihr ein richtig cooler
betrieb seither in deutschland schreibt
uns angelogen kleiner betrieb der
biologisch herstellt regional regional
herstellt
die coole familie hat eine tolle
geschichte wie kommt vor bald finden ist
die variante ja das war's eigentlich was
ich meine ihr könnt ihr mal schreiben
was euer highlight in diesem jahr auf
meinem kanal war
vielleicht habt ihr euer persönliches
highlight was wahre highlight motiv
torte was war das highlight rezept
vielleicht fällt euch was ein was uns
jetzt irgendwie durch den kopf gegangen
werden nicht durch den kopf gegangen ist
auf jeden fall muss ich sagen war es für
uns ein richtig cooles jahr sehr
intensiv natürlich mit dem bau die
messen waren wieder wunderschön mit
eucharistischer erblicke ich freue mich
im nächsten jahr wieder auf die
autogrammstunden auf die messen dass wir
uns da wieder sehen können und was den
vorsitzen ich muss sagen ich habe keine
vorsätze ich mein ich bin nichtraucher
schon immer das heißt das fällt weg
abnehmen zu nehmen will ich auch nicht
doch ich will mehr zum sport gehen
einfach um fit zu bleiben ich möchte
auch nicht wird also wo ich mich weniger
haare mehr kilos verlieren und wir zogen
es wichtig wäre haare mehr kilos noch
[Musik]
weniger machen mit kindern kann sogar
gar nicht genug zeiten ja das stimmt
die werden so schnell groß viel im
garten möchte ich mal drauf wenn man
gartenbauern lichtgarten videos kohle
geben in der bühne die pflanzen karotten
und kartoffeln schmecken kräuter weg
wird gemacht rollrasen ausgelegt coole
videos zum rollrasen linke paar richtig
coole tipps macht das hab ich dann
urlaub machen
nein ich helfe gerne coole geschichte
niemals damit nicht richtig also mir
gesagt schreibe es in die kommentare was
euer highlight war in diesem jahr was
ihr euch wünscht fürs nächste jahr und
ich bedanke mich bei euch alles fürs
zuschauen war ein cooles ja wirklich es
war richtig toll war echt spaß gemacht
wünschen wir euch ein schönes
silvesterfest ja und keine böller haben
besteht keine böller anzügen keine
bilder kaufen meine ganz coole
geschäftsjahr recht das war ja nur keine
umweltverschmutzung genau bis zum
nächsten jahr auch gut so auch jetzt
hält uns mal richtig schön ganzes
feuerwerk 7 ja und ja das schon mal
haupt zigaretten kann man abschaffen
so jetzt schön jetzt lassen sie uns auch
die ganzen raucher auch noch wollen ist
das so wenn ich sowas doch in energy
drink sagte mir er hat es geschafft
tja da mehrere was ist jetzt noch nicht
aber wenn ich mal präsidentin werde von
deutschland dann knapp ich das rauchen
ich will nämlich nicht dass die menschen
krank werden
so lassen sie uns auch noch ja und es
gibt doch so viele andere tolle ist auch
was sie sagen
die können doch ihre zeit und sonders
gehen die waffen erst renoviert ist
sowieso immer wieder wenn die sachen weg
wären ganz ehrlich dabei heitmann
weltfrieden warum so also macht's gut
macht's besser schönes neues jahr
morath und
eure sally bei 8 geschätzt wird das jahr
schön dass du noch bei mir wird uns so
lange mit mir aushält